Thank you for coming and thank Google
for providing a forum that people like me
making sure our ideas. So, um,
first I want to do is tell you a little
bit about the ad. My pace series.
This was the first book in case
you guys did not see it. And, uh,
what caused me to be,
what caused me to start with at my pace
with this whole idea was at the time
Cheryl Sandburg and had
her lean conversation and
everybody was running with
lean in except for a fair chunk of my
friends. And people I knew who fell.
It didn't apply to them. And
the question was, is there,
is there a story to be told about women
who aren't on the Autobahn going full
speed ahead?
Is there a story to be told about those
people who have a windy road with starts
and stops who were enjoying
life in a different kind of way?
And I could not find a book out there
that, uh, laid credence to that.
And so I decided that we
would write that book.
And I had is my model and the back of
my mind that this I believe series.
Does anybody know this? I believe, um,
it's really worth checking out some time.
So there are 500 word,
a very pithy pieces on different topics
that the high school students oftentimes
read. And you get a chance to see the
world. Too many different people's eyes.
But I knew that 500 words would not
capture the topics I was looking at.
So I said,
let's bump it up to a thousand words.
Let me do some guidelines
and let me help people.
I wanted people who were famous and
people who don't typically, right?
I wanted to get those voices out there.
It's the voices of the people that we,
most of us interact with every day.
Uh,
and I had the goal was to see the world
through many different perspectives and
the end of the day to
expand the conversation.
So that time it was about leaning
in and the woman's journey,
which I since have learned it,
have been the woman's journey.
It should of been the journey because
we all have the same challenges of how
we're going to do it.
Um,
and then at the end of it all and some
way in that process we would discover
something about ourselves
and find some truth. Uh,
that would mean something to us and why
it's at my pace is because even though
we live in a fast paced society,
finding out these truths or working our
way through these issues doesn't happen
that quickly.
It's some organic process.
And my hope was that these books would
help foster a conversation that would get
us to that place that we can
feel good about the topic.
So that was the first book.
Um,
I continue to give lots of
discussions with groups on that. Um,
but the second book, so then what
was happening was I was thinking,
is there another book in me?
And My mother was in her 91st year of
life and she wasn't doing that well.
And so she lived in Denver and I was
applying and see her every five or six
weeks I would be there.
I was always driving her crazy with,
are you drinking enough,
are you eating enough and it has a PT
going and just like you're teenagers can
sort of shut you down and sort of turn.
She was basically in not
wanting to engage in that.
So I decided I would change
the conversation and I
wrote her a piece on one
lesson I took from her
life and its impact on me.
And that lesson was about
continuous lifelong learning.
In her eighties she was
still taking classes. Uh,
she had very young classmates in her
class. One of the, one of the classes,
they gave her a rolling backpack because
they were afraid that she would fall as
she tried to carry these books.
And uh,
so there's my mother's rolling
backpack that even in her eighties,
she's taking classes. And I
realize that for me, I'm always,
I wasn't always working on my own.
I worked in different
established companies and I
was always told how curious I
was, you know, that I,
and I think that curiosity and that
wanting to learn came from her.
So I wrote my piece and then she
loved it. And then I thought, well,
this is going to be my next book.
I'm going to go ask people to write a
piece on their mother. Only one lesson,
not 10 story based and
it cannot be mushy gushy.
That was just me cause I'm
not a big mushy gushy fan,
so it turns out that mushy gushy was
really not that much in the cards anyway
because people have very complex
feelings about their mothers.
Oftentimes, not always oftentimes. So I'm
going to show you the cover of the book.
This was the cover as you have it there
and my question to you is what do you
think?
I was thinking when I had a fledgling,
what they flower and a mother
bird looking down what?
What do you think was in my thoughts?
Okay, I'm going to help you guys.
Why Was it judgment. Gratitude.
Yeah.
I wanted this,
this fledgling had a flower and to me
was a sign of giving back a saying thank
you. Now it turns out that
sometimes it's not a flower.
Sometimes it's an olive branch.
Sometimes is putting your mother and
context and being able to explain her to
yourself and being able to
validate that relationship.
And I mentioned that I have guidelines
when I go through this with contributors
and this guideline,
I said,
you may not discuss your mom if it turns
out that you cannot get to that place,
that you can put her in context and
appreciate her then it's not the book for
you. And some people couldn't. I had
a one woman who wrote me and she said,
I've tried three times to write my piece.
It is still a rant.
So I thank you cause I'm
going to see a therapist now.
And I had um,
we were just talking about dogs.
I have a dog that I love dearly and I
went to take him to my groomer. I said,
oh by the way, I got this book, how
would you like one of these books?
And she's like, it's
about mom from like, Yep,
I have a really complicated
relationship with my mom. I'm like,
well you don't have to take it.
No, no worries. I was just, Oh,
I'll take you to them. I've been a
customer should probably felt obliged.
And then when I came
back the next go around,
she said to me that was so meaningful
because I have never been at peace with my
mom. I read the book, I wrote
a piece, she and I cried.
It was a very healing moment.
So I had a lot of things like that happen.
So what I want to do today is two things.
I want to talk about the flower and the
olive branch. The people who were just,
you know, had, uh,
sort of sheer appreciation
and the olive branch,
the people who really had to struggle
to put their mother in context.
And I give you guys a feeling I would
get my reading glasses so I can actually
read a little bit, uh, and give,
give you guys a feeling for what I
heard and what I took away from it all.
So we want to hear all of
branches or flowers first.
Okay. If you guys aren't voting, I'm
going from flowers. All right. So, um,
there's a story here called rough,
rough patch and rough patch is run by
Laurel Lloyd is a woman whose mother,
when she was young, all she wanted
to do was drama. Now her parents,
one was a teacher when was a nurse
and she lived in that stage of,
of living where parents seem to be able
to actually dictate what their kids did.
And so her parents said to her,
you can do drama on the side,
but you're not going to do that.
You're going to be a teacher.
That's a nice solid career.
You can support yourself.
So she taught but she didn't like it and
she ended up reverting back to drama.
And that's what she did. And then
one summer when she was doing drama,
she met what would become
her husband on the stage.
At the end of the summer they were engaged
and they then went ahead and had four
kids.
They left New York City and they headed
to Vermont and they raised their kids in
a very small town in Vermont.
He had a small hardware store.
She was a mom who did PTA and girl scouts.
And sort of additional role.
She didn't have too much time to
act on almost no time, a little bit.
Occasionally he was still doing acting
on the side and Laurel remembered that's
somewhere in the 20 year
mark of their marriage.
They hit this rough patch and uh,
at 23 years in their marriage they get
divorced when he was onstage and one of
his shows,
he met an actress.
They fell in love and that was
the end of his marriage to his,
to his wife. So Laurel
describes that moment. Um,
when she says about her mother,
she felt rejected and alone.
But at age 50,
she picked herself up and move forward.
In the years that followed,
my mother acted in multiple
theaters outside of our town.
She got a degree in counseling,
worked as a counselor and I local high
school and at a local shelter with teens,
she became the caretaker of a refugee
Guatemalan family helping to raise five
children while working at a, at
a Benedictine monastery. In time,
her relationship with my dad healed
and they often shattered when seen each
other in town.
Now,
the weird thing is that Laurel
telling the story as an adult,
she was married for 20 years,
hit the same rough patch and literally
23 years into her marriage at age 50,
she gets divorced.
Actually divorce goes through on the
exact day of what would have been her
parents' anniversary.
And so she's feeling all over again like
remembering her mother and the pain and
she got, she described,
um, with a young daughter.
It was inevitable that I'd be seen my ex
and eventually his wife because her ex
also had a, uh, had a new
woman who actually lived,
moved into the house.
What that Laura moved out of a,
so I braced myself and
put my best foot forward.
I went back to work and
began to rebuild my life.
Five years since our split, my ex and
I have moved beyond our difficult time.
My goal during the hurt of the divorce
was that we would find our way back to a
positive place and it has happened.
I even had Thanksgiving dinner at my
former home this past year with my ex,
his wife, her ex, their son, my daughter.
And some other guests. And then
she shakes includes, she said, my,
my friend stifled a gasp when I told her
I'd be having Thanksgiving dinner with
my ex and his wife.
But isn't that how it should be?
Letting go of the adversity in our lives
appreciating the good and what was and
moving on in the end is
the children who win.
And that's the lesson that my mother
taught me with the grace and kindness.
She showered on those in her life.
A gift that I'll be sure
to pass on to my daughter.
So the same rough patch that her mother
had was the same rough patch that she
had and she was able to take her mother's
equanimity and strength and copied
that when she had her moment.
Um, by the way, this is,
feel free to ask questions
or interject a comment.
Am supposed to be
informal and interactive.
Okay, I'll give you another story.
That's what I call a flower story.
This is a shorter one. So, um,
the story is that, uh, at least freed
men who's in her seventies, remember,
is being in Maui, uh,
traveling with her husband,
super excited to get up early in the
morning and go tour tour of the island and
their upgrade early and they're stuck
in traffic because there is a big dump
truck filled with pineapples
that's blocking the road.
She had just filled with pineapples.
So she's sort of laughing
at the peculiarity up early
to go see the island and
who you are in traffic because of a,
of a truck of pineapples.
And she calls her mother who lives
in buffalo now. First of all,
she's on her cell phone. This is the 70s.
And her mother first was like in shock.
Oh my gosh, you're calling me from
Hawaii on our phone and Buffalo.
So that was sort of cool. Then when they
got through that, uh, Elise says, bye mom,
I'm calling you because we are stuck in
traffic because there is a dump truck
and in front of us filled with pineapples.
And so her mother says, well, Elise,
have you tried the pineapples too?
Which at least has mom, you know,
I don't eat pineapple,
at least describes herself as a person
who always fished the pineapple out of
any fruit before she would even start to
have the fruit cup. And her mother says,
Elise, be a grownup, try the pineapple.
So she actually decides to listen to her
mother and she tries to pineapple later
that day and she finds out the Lo and
behold the pineapple in Hawaii is way
different than any
pineapple she's ever tasted.
And then she later that day goes to one
of those gift stores where they can find
that exact kind of pineapple that
she can chip to her mother as a okay.
So she does that and she heads back
home and then two weeks later she gets a
call from her sister and buffalo and
her sister says that her mother has,
their mother has just had a stroke.
So at least immediately
goes to buffalo visit mom.
And at the end of the day she goes to
her apartment and she opens up the fridge
to go get some water.
And there she sees the pineapple.
I needin never to beaten by her mother
who can't swallow anymore, right there,
you know,
unwrapped.
And she has a very big learning
moment for herself right there.
And I'm going to say it in her words.
She writes,
I have a tendency to be rather
emphatic and my opinions,
some of which I may have formed without
a whole lot of reasonable evidence.
Every so often I am an a miss of holding
forth explaining why I would never ever
consider doing this or that.
And then I hear my mother cautioning me,
Elise, she is saying be
a grownup. So for her,
the pineapple was about opening up her
mind and really taking the world fresh
and not bringing her her
prejudices to that instance.
So those are some flower stories.
Anybody have a lesson they want
to share about their mother?
Something that they've took.
It was on the sweet side of life.
Do we want some olive branch stories?
Okay,
well we'll go for an olive
branch story. So, uh,
there's a story in this book
called emotional blinders,
and it's a story of a man named Martin
Abramowitz, who's in his seventies.
His father was a cutter for the triangle
shirt factory. Who knows what the,
who does anybody know about
the Red Triangle? Shirt
factory? Okay. So we have that,
that was a factory that it was a moment
of tragedy went up and fire and many,
many girls were, were killed. This,
I don't remember what the year was,
but it was early 1900.
His father was a cutter for the factory.
He remembers his father was not a, well
man, he was in and out of the hospital.
Mari remembers visiting him,
but not being able to go into the hospital
because they didn't like kids into
the hospital. He would have to be in the
outside, sort of at the window waving.
And Marty has an older
brother, 10 years older. Um,
so one day his mother tells him that
his father has gone to Florida to
convalesce.
Um,
and he sort of takes it at face value.
He remembers that day.
It turned out to be the
day of his dad's funeral,
but the mother has lied and told him that
the has moved to Florida to convalesce.
He says, I remember what I'm
sure. With a day of that funeral,
my brother walked me to school
on that rainy march morning.
I still see the expanding raindrop circles
in the pedals on our block and feel
the sadness is I put my boots and rain
coat away in the walk in closet at the
back of my second grade classroom and
that's all he remembers. No funeral,
no Vizard desert home,
no weeping mother,
no words of huge or hugs with
constellation or processing of any kind,
any proceeds along this path that his
dad is in Florida and two years pass,
no phone calls, no letters, no anything.
And finally he's goes to his
mother and he says, daddy is dead,
isn't t and what she is.
What he explains then as
the impact of that lie,
because I hit absorbed the
lesson and my mother's decision,
don't acknowledge death,
don't notice pain.
Don't pay attention to any feelings.
A low level won't go away.
Sadness that you won't put it into words
works as a strategy to avoid pain and
get through life. But that has, uh,
an impact on I repercussion in his life
because he describes as an older person.
Um, he was a failed
partner, a failed parent.
He couldn't find any real energy for life.
He has a very active mind,
but something that was just a lethargy
about how he did life because he had so
learned to oppress his feelings.
And when I asked her if they
wanted to write a piece,
he wants to write a piece because it was
his chance to explain to himself and to
his children, to his grandchildren
why his mother did that.
And he saw it in a whole different light
and he was able to put peace, know,
find some piece of himself.
So I'm going to reach you how
he puts it in perspective.
He says, I have come to understand
Rosie's decision through a different Lens.
One that has a much more positive lesson.
A widow at 42 with one acting out
17 year old son and the other,
a frail seven year old and no
income except social security.
Rosie seems to have put
on emotional blinders.
She never be wailed or situation.
Never looked for a man.
Instead she said about making sure
she could support her family by hand,
sewing labels on men's neckties.
My brother and I have that memory of
trying to keep up with her as she would go
full speed ahead navigating
the isles of Macy's,
not looking back to see if
we were even keeping pace.
So Rosie's decision to avoid pain was
also about getting on with the business of
life.
She was smart enough to know
that some instinctive level,
what she needed to do was to keep
her family and our lives intact.
I have enormous respect for her ability
to have done that and have taught me a
survival skill even as I'm
more her losses and mine.
So, um, I asked him why he, he wrote this,
I mean he's been living with us
for many years. I think for him,
he really wanted to codify
that experience, what it
meant to him at the time,
what it means to him now and how he
can love and respect her decisions.
Even if for a very
large chunk of his life.
It has some very
detrimental effects on him.
It's hard not to be judgmental.
Very hard.
Yeah. Right. And to see, I mean,
and also that older brother who knew,
right? Can you imagine being the brother,
the 17 year old brother,
10 years older,
who knew the [inaudible] had to
actually keep the lie as well.
So there's probably a lot
of ways to emp unpack that.
Then it was damaging and a lot
of ways. Um, I had a woman,
so I always try and these stories to
reach out to groups that are not Newton
Jewish. That's sort of my sweet
spot and Newton Jewish. But I try,
I try to reach out to other
parts of the universe. Um,
I was much more successful in the second
book in this book that I was in the
first book and successful
getting the third book.
So I reached out to a woman
who is from Ghana and uh,
her parents, uh, her mother
was a little more, um, on the,
on the social caste of society.
Her mother was higher on the rung than
her father. They lived in the, in Ghana.
Her father was a police officer
who made his way up to, um,
I think a military officer or some kind.
They had four daughters.
And uh,
at some point their parents get divorced
and she is now living with her mother
and her grandmother and she
misses her father terribly.
And so the father decides every Saturday
he's going to come visit the four
daughters and he's going to
have a good day with them.
And this happens routinely.
And so it's all very copacetic.
And then one Saturday when he's visiting
a military truck comes by and says to
her, father, you have to
go. And so he zooms away.
It turns out it was Ghana was in the
middle of a coup and he was on the side of
trying to repress the COO and he had to
go see if he could repress the COO in
the course of the coup.
He died, he was killed.
So now she has her mother,
her grandmother.
And then what happens is she married the
mother remarries and I don't know what
the name of this man is because he was
only referred to with a capital h as him
sort of like or Baltimore.
He shall not be named as
him and him is abusive.
And I'm not sure if it's
emotional or physical or both,
but he's definitely abusive and she is
very angry at her mother because her
mother never stands up for them.
The grandmother is a big believer in,
uh, has been, has a big believer in
faith and God goes to church every week,
sings in the choir and the
grandmother says to this woman,
you will find your salvation in the Lord.
You are meant to serve the Lord.
You will take your pain and all this
and that will be where you put it.
And so she does, she goes to church
and she sings and she loves all that.
And at a certain point she decided she's
going to the states because she has to
get away from him and she's angry at her
mother and she's able to come here and
she actually does become a reverend.
Now.
I asked her if she would write a story
about her mother. I didn't know all this.
I just know that she got an insane to me.
How about my grandmother kind of
write about my grandmother and I said,
well you can, um, but you know,
it's a book about mothers,
but if grandma's or what you want
to honor of, fine, we can do that.
And then I don't hear from her. And
as usually happens in, at my pace,
you put out a lot of,
you cast a big net and you get some eel,
but some people drop out
for different reasons.
And I thought she was going to drop out.
And then she calls me and she says,
I'm coming over.
And she walks into my door,
I'm out of my house and she's a reverend.
And she says to me,
the Lord has brought you to me.
And I thought that I was
like in a dreamland imagining
this. And she said, again,
the Lord has brought you to me
and I don't. Okay, what did I do?
And what I did was make her revisit her
past and make her find peace with her
mother. And so I'm going to read you
the end. She calls her peace, peace.
She actually called me recently and
said, um, I have some 30 somethings.
Can they write in your 20 something
book? I'm like, no, it was 20 something
but I do 30 somethings. I'll come back
to you. So here's what she writes.
At the end of peace, she writes,
it is over four decades later.
And today I am a reverend,
I have moved my mom to the
states and him has died.
I have two children. And while I am
not their friend, I am their ear.
I support and guide them. And my second
husband has also committed to them.
I think the Lord daily.
And I have forgiven my mom for not
supporting my sisters and me after my dad
died.
It has taken a while,
but I have found my peace and
hopefully she has found hers.
So that is a pure olive branch story
that is somebody who had a lot of
consternation,
a lot of anger and was able to in the
course of writing a piece find her piece.
So, uh, I think what's
interesting to me is I,
I speak about this book, uh, to
groups, synagogues, community places,
you name it. But I haven't had a
chance to take it into the work set.
And even though I wanted to,
and I think that the lessons are mothers
applies as much to work as it does and
to any community setting you could because
we take our lessons from our mom with
us for good or for bad. There they are
us. And that's what we bring to work.
And I had this lunch a while back where
I was telling him one of my clients
about the book and he
pulls out his cell phone.
Now he works at a technology company.
He has about 200 people in
his organization that he
manages and he shows me the,
whenever he feels um,
overwhelmed or just sort of
daunted by the challenges.
He looks at this note that his
mother hand wrote for him years ago.
So his mother was an
immigrant from Ireland.
She came over and when she
was 16 she knew nobody.
There was an Irish community
here in Boston that was helpful.
She became a clerk at Jordan Marsh and
she worked all the way up to executive
buyer and she wrote for her two kids
this thing called the ladder of success.
And she, he showed me, I think I will, I
can, I did. And it has percentages by it.
And so he looks at that handwritten note
when he feels like the world's just a
little bigger than he wants it to
be a little more, a little harder.
And when I asked him what that was about,
he tells me two stories.
The first story is that they went to
church every Sunday and when they went to
church there would be a series of people
from a halfway house in the back of the
church and the first thing she would do,
excuse me,
and she would go up and shake everybody's
hand and as part of the halfway house,
evidently that was unusual because most
people didn't do that and she offered
people afterwards rides home and
he said he took from that the the,
the way she was able to extend
dignity and respect to everybody,
no matter your lot in life and that
was something he wanted to make sure he
copied.
The second memory he had was on July 4th
before they could go do the big parade
and celebrate. She said, you have to
clean up and it wasn't clean up inside.
The house was cleaning up outside and
it wasn't just clean up the lawn and the
sidewalk was going down the block
and seeing if there was any garbage,
any refuse to pick up because she wanted
him to understand that accountability
was more than just about your area here.
It was about really extending a much
bigger arm and being able to take
responsibility for a bigger piece
of the world than just your lot.
So he looks at this,
this ladder of success,
and he thinks about how he treats
people and he thinks about how he builds
accountability within his things.
And that's,
that's his lesson from his
mother that he takes into work.
So now I'm going to ask you guys,
is there a lesson that anybody in this
room can imagine that you'd take into
work?
Something that your mother has given
you that you can see a connection to and
how you behave at work?
My mother used to always say what
her mother said to her, which is,
if you can't say something nice,
don't say anything at all.
And I think that's really important
to sometimes to be positive,
not be overly critical,
and certainly think about it
before you're negative about stuff.
Right? Oh, that's a good one. Just
being positive goes a long way.
Oh, there's, there's a lot of lessons. Um,
there's a really funny story
in this book by Danny Brazel.
It's called always talking
and he describes his mother.
Actually. It's so funny,
I'm going to read you a
part of it and she just,
she's married to a quiet librarian.
He is very happy to give his wife the,
you know, the running of the house.
So he started off, mom loves to talk.
It can drive a person nuts.
My mother has received a piece of mail
that she did not feel compelled to read
aloud to anyone in the room. So
Danny, you remember Mrs a language.
She'll say she died four
years before you were born.
Why just received a letter from her
daughter. Let me read it to you.
And then she'll read about a letter
of someone I do not know about,
things I do not care about.
And like Walt Disney,
no matter what travail she described,
she always manages to find a silver
lining to create a happy ending.
And then she, he described being in
the car with her. She's always talking.
I don't ever remember sitting in the car
with my mother throughout my childhood
where she did not play some sort
of game with us kids. Hey Danny,
there's a Volkswagen bug she pointed out
while smacking me in the arm. Hey Dan,
I look at the license plates on the car.
How many different states can you spot?
Hey Daddy,
what sounds does your name start with?
I'd make a d sound and she would challenge
me if I'm sounding to started with
this sound dairy queen and
shout back donuts. Yes,
I wasn't obese child.
My poor father could never get a
word in or anyone for that matter.
When my mother began speaking,
so honey,
tell daddy who was on the plane with us
and as my father began to open his mouth,
mother would blurt out the
San Francisco giants and hey,
tell Danny what they says to you.
And Dad would make another
fruitless attempt to speak.
Mom would share the rest of the
story. So he says at the end, now,
mom always has something to say.
And I am now a motivational
speaker who gets paid to talk.
Who Do you think I took after?
Yeah.
Anyway, it's uh, I think if,
I think it's really interesting and may
be helpful to think about the lessons
that cut off. Let me listen to your
father give you, has given him.
But this book has it from
my mom dedicated to my mom.
So that was why I chose mothers.
But I think who we are at home is mostly
who we are at work and the lessons from
our parents are very much a factor
and who that person is. Uh, yeah. I'm,
I'm happy to take any questions.
I think you'd be more stories but you
got the book so you can read it yourself.
Um, but if you have any questions
or thoughts, I'm happy to take them.
I'll offer another story,
a lesson from my father.
Just cause you mentioned fathers.
I remember being a little
kid and complaining about
having to go to school and
I've got a 17 year old daughter now
and gives me the same thing about
complaining about going to school.
But when I was a kid and I was just so
upset I didn't want to go to school as a
waste of my time. I didn't like school
and my dad said to me, you know,
I go to work every day. I don't want to
go to work every day. You just do it.
Right. Right. And that kind
of stayed with me. Right.
Sometimes there's things
you got to do right
now. What you want to just not tell
the truth what you gotta do. Yeah, no,
that's true. Well, sometimes when we get
into these rooms, especially of signing,
when I've gotten through with a lot of
the sweet spot for me in this book is
Middle Age women who are contemplating
and trying to sort of think back about
their moms and about their life.
And it's just so interesting to see how
their decisions were driven by a memory
of their mother and what they take
with it. So, um, and my daughter,
I was saying to earlier,
some people were hearing,
my daughter wrote it wanting to
write a piece and I was like, no,
you don't need to write a piece. It's
not about me. It's about the world.
I didn't know that. I want to
write a piece. And she writes,
actually a really good piece,
a, even though I didn't
want her to, and her lesson,
I always said to her,
Naomi,
responsibility goes up and credit goes
down and she works at Boston scientific.
And she always tells me that that's,
those are words that have always stuck
with her responsibility of credit down.
Because you know,
you're oftentimes in teams,
which don't give enough credit to
the people who are doing the work.
And it's very easy for someone
who is further up in the chain to,
to take the credit. Not that it happens
here, but I'm saying, but it would be, uh,
an inclination that, that you could just
be aware of. So I was happy to hear that.
Some words that, uh, I had said as
a mom actually made it into a piece.
Um, but it's good. So, uh,
I think if you guys are thinking about
a creative present for your mother,
you could,
uh,
give her a copy of the book or your copy
of the book and you could write her a
little note as people have done.
I had one woman who said to me,
I would not have been able to write a
piece for this book because I would have
been all about dissing my mom. So I
said, okay, tell me about your mom. Well,
she's 94 and what does she do?
Well, she plays a lots of games.
Canasta she listed a whole bunch of games
that she plays and I said to her and
tell them I happen to know a little bit
about this woman and not a lot. I said,
tell me what you like to do a wash.
There's a lot. I play games too.
And she actually teaches game,
just one of her hobbies that she gets
paid to teach games. So I said to her,
and you can't find any gift to there about
your mother and her nineties and then
you read I think games player as well.
And then she saw me as a couple of weeks
later and she said to me, thank you,
because I'm actually going to
going to thank my mom for that.
And she didn't think she had anything
in her, but she actually did.
So that has come up in so many different
ways where people have had a chance to
thank their mother. So it's a late
February, last day of February,
managed days in May and you have a
couple of months you could ratio,
you could write your mother a little
note and I give her the book and she
probably would think it's about one
of the nicest presence she could have.
Hmm.
Thank you guys for coming. I know
you guys are busy. If you have,
I'm happy to take questions but if you
don't have questions and I'll let you
guys get back to work.
I have one question.
Did you notice the difference mothers
and sons versus mothers and daughters
pieces?
Um, not so much. Actually.
I really, I really did not.
The men who stepped up and wanted
to write, we're for the most part,
men who were very comfortable sharing
their emotions and didn't have a,
so I would say that I
didn't see so much of that.
I actually originally thought this would
be a book about mothers and daughters
and my son who is my copy
editor, said, well, you know,
sending along or write
about your mother's too.
And it was like a new idea to me that
sounds what actually speak about their
mothers. And so then I went
running around, I'm like,
why catch us have two men in
the book or one man in the book.
So then I went around
and started asking men,
do you want to write about your mother?
And the biggest constraint was just
either time or people very uncomfortable
with their writing skills.
That's a big theme I have and these
books is people will say, well,
I have ideas but I'm not a writer.
And I always say,
you don't have to be a writer.
I will help you.
You gotta you have to have thoughts,
but we can take your thoughts
and we can make a piece.
And they're so happy afterwards because
they wouldn't have done it on their own.
Um, but yeah, but I think the,
I see difference in age more than
I see a difference in gender.
Yeah. The older you get, the
more appreciative it's everyone.
The younger stories are
angsty, you know. Um, so yeah,
I think that last comment about the
age thing seems to me, you know,
as you got older you,
uh,
you've experienced more life
and you bump into these things.
A lot of the lessons that I feel like
I'm starting to learn or as I understand
myself and go inside myself and
learn more about my own character and
personality and the way it
handle situations, right.
As we an appreciation for the
way my mom handled herself,
we went through a divorce, my father's
business went bankrupt, uh, uh,
before that and then,
and then she went through a divorce.
But the way she handled
herself, um, and the,
the one thing that struck me through this
whole thing was the way that she sings
all day long around the house
doing anything. And that Sensei, I,
I carry that same, uh, like
musical sentence with me. So, uh,
I just catch myself sometimes doing the
dishes while the kids are getting ready
to go to school and he's just repeating
it, doing the same kind of thing.
Any song, it could be one of the
kids tunes, it could be Abbo,
which my mom used to love or whatever it
is, and I'll do it sound like I'm crazy.
But then I turned around and to
see the kids doing the same thing,
walking around the house,
singing to themselves about while
they're doing tasks and it's just,
it's just a cascading like
genetic or just a crazy,
but that's a lovely thing
to pass through generation,
but to be able to write it.
Yeah.
And I think the age part of that is the
tie in there was that just being able to
recognize that you get to a certain
age where you start to see all these
different pieces of your mother and uh,
the things that you hated it one time.
You then you're either
experiencing it with your own
daughters or, yeah. Oh, sons.
Oh, uh, oh. You just learn more about
yourself and how you handled it. Yeah,
that's true. That's definitely true. Lacy.
Yeah, I'll just second that. But it
occurred to me that like, right. Um,
I was born when my mother was almost 30,
so I haven't gotten to the point yet
where I am really like doing any of the
things that I saw her doing.
Right.
I've been married almost four months
now and like I'm just starting to see
things where I'm like, oh my gosh, I'm
like doing this just like my mom or like,
you know, all these things she used
to remind me about. I'm like, oh I'm,
this is where it's useful.
Then I'm like just starting to be in the
kind of situations. But I saw her in,
right.
We love that as parents,
we love when we see that our kids don't
think that what we did was just crazy.
But there actually was some
reason behind it all. Well,
keep your eyes open for ways you're like
your parents and then if they're at all
flattering you can, um, let them know.
Cause it's always good as a parent
to have a moment of recognition.
Well thank you all for coming
today. I appreciate that. Thank you.